you know part of me does kind of wish
that tenants prediction came true and
his regeneration was caused by him
tripping on a brick
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there folks overdue Doctor Who
review time and first to let you know
that this particular episode of Council
of geeks is brought to you by the radio
versus the Martians podcast as a podcast
it's free and available on most a
podcast streaming platforms and you can
listen to Mike Gillis and Casey Doran
the hosts talked about all kinds of
geeky things whether it be ghostbusters
whether it be Planet of the Apes whether
it be Batman or whether it be Arnold
Schwarzenegger and all of the crazy
macho stuff he's done on film over the
years so all of that stuff and much more
with a rotating stable of guest Brady
vs. the Martians at Radio versus the
Martians calm or wherever you get your
podcasts and so it's time that now that
we are off series four to start working
our way through the specials and we
begin with the next Doctor so this one I
mean it's a Christian this one's a
Christmas special specifically and it
comes up regularly my opinion of the
Christmas specials overall is not
especially high I don't think all that
much of them they're just kind of there
for me you know they're fun they're
light and for the most part that's what
this is - basically there's a couple of
elements that I love and a couple like a
couple of elements that I wish were
better and then some stuff that's like
okay that's just kind of there and I
feel like in many ways that's the
Christmas specials in a nutshell so
we've got the doctor back in Victoria
era London and he runs into a very suave
boisterous kind of full of himself guy
who claims to be the doctor played by
david Morrissey and obviously Tennant's
initial assumption is that he is if not
the next immediate a
future regeneration of himself well that
turns out to not be what's going on but
there's definitely something going on
because the man does believe this very
sincerely he has a companion with him a
woman named Rosita he has what he claims
as a sonic screwdriver he has a TARDIS
of a kind and he is chasing down
Cybermen because yes there are Cybermen
in Victorian London and they're up to
something
they've gotten in league with a woman
named miss Hartigan and she's one of the
elements that I wish worked because I
feel like you know what I want you know
what I want with her I want to read the
full character backstory that I'm sure
exists on a notepad somewhere that they
came up with but never got to use any of
because you know she's just here to be
the villain but I have I feel like she's
probably got a really exhaustive and
interesting backstory and history in
this world
I kinda wanna know what drove this woman
to side with the Cybermen and do the
things she does we get hints of it we've
get this whole thing of this that you
know she's tired of being oppressed and
ignored but at the same time like I feel
like okay so you you seem to have a
legitimate vendetta against for lack of
a better term well-off men okay but
you're totally chill with killing kids
cuz bunch of kids are come with the plan
you know and that's not to say that
doesn't work I'm sure you could no prize
it maybe she just is that heartless but
I feel like I needed to get to know her
slightly better than we actually get to
do and this especially considering that
her supposedly her willpower is so
strong that that is what defeats the
Cybermen in a very cheesy she's gonna
scream so loud that everybody blows up
including herself it's it's it's a it
happens in a really bad shot to be
completely honest
but given how much she factors into a
lot of what goes on in the tale land I
kind of wish we we knew more about her
in specific and got to know her a bit
better David more see as the dr. ish and
then later on as Jackson Lake once he
realizes who he actually is is an
interesting thing as well because when
he is quote-unquote the doctor he is
more or less tenant like cranked up to
11
just a little more arrogant just a
little more boisterous just a little
more assuming he's in control of
everything which are all qualities that
tenant has but he's just cranked him up
ever so slightly he borders on grading
but like in a way that feels deliberate
and kind of makes a certain amount of
sense yeah
sense given what it is that's going on
with him he's latching on to this
persona of the doctor and yeah he's
gonna really dive into it and ramp it up
a bit
but the thing is once he gets his memory
back and he gets to be Jackson Lake
again I think david morrissey is
brilliant I I like him when he thinks
he's the doctor I love him when he's
Jackson light cuz the bravado falls away
and the humanity comes forward the the
sense of loss the sense of fear that and
and it's not like it's just suddenly
boom it's just it seeps into the
performance and yet he still has just
enough of sort of that that gung-ho
nature leftover from when he thought he
was the doctor that it that it keeps him
going I really loved his performance and
there's something about when he realized
that he didn't just lose his wife but
that his child was taken there's
something about his performance as that
revelation hits him and he looks up and
there's his son standing on this ledge
tearing up and too scared to move oh oh
that's in the fields for me both those
performances anything you know I say
performance for the kid kid doesn't do
much but know he's got he's got a great
look great huge wide wet eyes like no
that works
um but yeah that that hits me that hits
me a bit and I also really love at the
end where like because he's kind of been
the doctor but he's he's got the
doctor's number he knows the doctor
needs a companion even though the doctor
is currently in a state of denial on
that and I love him stepping into the
TARDIS and just calling it wonderful
nonsense and so very silly and then
design no it's too much and got a light
I love it I love it so much like I wish
there was a reasonable way to bring him
back like I don't know what you do with
it I don't know how you could do it
without it feeling contrived but I
really do like him a lot as far as the
Cybermen go they are about what they've
been since they've been reintroduced
into knew who they are functional they
get the job done the cyber shades are a
little goofy but then again it's the
Christmas special the story's a little
goofy cyber King is a little much but
then later on the fact that like nobody
seems to remember it actually becomes a
bit of a plot point in later seasons
although I'm not sure it was initially
designed to be that but you know it's I
mean it's fine I think part of the
reason I don't quite gel with the cyber
King is it gives me flashbacks to the
movie wild wild west because she's in
this giant you know walking this giant
robot shooting fireballs saying you will
you know you will bow to me why aren't
they
subjugating to me and it just makes me
think of wild wild west and this
insanely hammy performance from Kenneth
Branagh as he strolls up in a mechanical
spider and demands that the entire
United States be seated
over to him like I can't help but get
that same vibe and it makes makes it
harder for me to take it seriously and
again I grant it's the Christmas special
I don't know how seriously I'm meant to
be taking it but I'd like to take him
more seriously than I would take wild
wild west and it does give me that vibe
a little bit I haven't talked too much
about Tennant he's he's good you can see
the kid gloves and he's kind of handling
Jackson with and I like that I that's
part of what I like about their dynamic
he's he's very concerned about about
Jackson even before he fully realizes
what the guy's deal is and and I like
that that even during a period in which
he thinks he doesn't need to be
traveling with a companion he still has
that level of care he hasn't shut off
his ability to be concerned he just
doesn't think he needs somebody else on
the TARDIS with him so I like that they
could have made him much colder you know
in the wake of losing Donna the way he
did but I like the kind of balance has
found that he's kind of put himself into
a bit of a self-exile but his nature as
just needing to be around people is
still there and I like that IRA Xena's
fun she's sassy yeah it's pretty oh you
know it was a cool little moment that I
didn't even I don't think I caught
before when miss Hartigan has the the
four guys that she has me oh they get
the ear pods in and she has them turn
right turn left the same way that lumix
head guy did back in the original
Cybermen to buy her like turned to the
right turn to the left
and you know just kind of get and
getting a kick out of it I kind of liked
that they repeated that beat with her I
don't I don't think I ever noticed that
before it's the sort of things you catch
when you're when you're binging through
while I say binge it's not like I'm
doing it like it rapid-fire back-to-back
night after night but going through
these in more rapid succession than was
around their original airdates means I'm
catching some of this stuff that I
missed the before in terms of the
connections and things like that
and
kind of fun not that it's like a major
plot point but it's practically an
easter-egg and I enjoyed it so overall I
think this is decent it's probably about
middling honestly maybe even higher-end
as far as the Christmas special
specifically go but given that I think
less of the Christmas specials in
general than I do of the the standard
episodes of Doctor Who you know I
realize I'm grading on a curve when I
say that but the next doctor what did
you think of it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down on the pot and
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff to do down there as well
there's the like button really
appreciate it subscribe if you haven't
already appreciate that too
there's the patreon definitely
appreciate that but there's all this
other stuff take a look at it or don't
I'm not gonna tell you what to do cuz at
the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just runnin the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]